this is a euro it's the currency used by
19 of the 28 seen to be 27 member states
at the EU as their currency and it's
administered by the European Central
Bank and the European Central Bank
invited me to Sintra Portugal or now now
to interview a bunch of PhD students but
not PhD students in science while
atmospheric science like me but PhD
students in economics and in replying to
them I am I had one question which I
feel like a lot of you would also have
what's the European Central Bank
[Music]
the European Central Bank is unlike a
commercial bank you can't take out a
loan from it for example and it's
priorities are different from that the
commercial bank it's not intended to
make profit for private shareholders
instead its purpose is to maintain price
stability and contribute to the overall
financial stability assisting the ECB is
the central bank for the 19 member
states which have adopted the euro as
their currency and its main purpose is
to maintain price stability so for
example making sure that the price of a
Fredo doesn't change too much over time
in the medium-term
how does the ECB Dunas well through
monetary policies such as setting
interest rates and as well as this the
ECB issues bank notice to the 340 or
million people who live in the euro zone
as well as supervising the banks in the
euro zone for their safety and soundness
to do it so I'm here in central for next
couple of days talking to economists and
talking to PhD students about what it's
like to do a PhD in economics what the
European Central Bank does in a bit more
detail and what research is being talked
about here now I really don't know
anything about economics so I asked you
guys for help on social media for
questions I could ask and you have sent
in droves of them I'm going to do my
best to try and ants get answers for at
least some of them
[Music]
you're trying to make sure that the
model is as simple as possible and the
assumptions are as simple to understand
as possible to make a particular point
they are trying to focus on so one
approach is to construct a very big
model that people call you know the
kitchen sink approach incorporate every
single feature of the economy
incorporate the shape of the factory
incorporate the mood of the people
incorporated but in reality you want to
make sure that everything is kept as
Fossum Onias that's possible given the
particular point they are trying to make
so what you just saw was on Monday which
is the first day of the conference
everyone was arriving and I'm now in a
suit because the conference itself
proper is happening now yesterday what I
did was interview a bunch of PhD
students those opposed to competition
that's happening for PhD students in
economics and I was interviewing a bunch
of the people who are up for an award
and you have already hopefully seen that
video come out on my channel what I'm
doing today is editing that video but
also trying to get more answers to your
questions so I asked you on social media
for your questions about what to ask
these students and what to ask the
economists and between editing I'm going
to be going out and experiencing the
conference
seeing what it's like and yeah trying to
get answers so it's part of this quest
for answers we e and that is me and
Monica who is desperately trying to stay
out frame are going over to where the
conference is happening so we've been
the office is over in the hotel here
which is this incredibly nice hotel and
the conference itself is happening over
there over this noise and the conference
itself is happening more so like other
academic conferences because this is
this is hosted by the European Central
Bank but the thing about central banks
is as I understand now they have a link
between policy and research so there
there's economic research going on as
well as sort of setting interest rates
and financial policy and things like
that and so behind me this is the poster
session so this is actually reading why
I'm here this is for the Pope the PhD
students who are at the conference and
presenting their work and there's a
competition going on for the young for a
prize so what's going to happen in a
second is all of these are super
important academics and the economists
are going to come out and talk to the
PhD students like at any academic
conference in front of their posters so
I'm basically Timah dating
[Music]
[Music]
you know it's funny I could see the
similarities with what I've given
posters before it made blogs back and in
conferences this feels exactly the same
anything that's missing from a
scientific conference is the booze
there's always beer or wine at
scientific conferences here you've got
PhD students who are asked to talk about
and defend their work people who are the
literal experts set monetary policy all
over the world so it's a little bit
intimidating I was just chatting to some
of them about how it's very flattering
but also scary to be doing this and I
completely remember that feeling so I'm
here with wrong way in speech yesterday
you've been talking to a bunch of very
important people and I've got to say
with a very well designed poster I'll
included closer I think you've got the
best poster here but what the people
would ask you is like definitely
very public address teacher
so they're asking you how they can do
their jobs better thanks to research
we're just going to event like hundreds
of millions of
okay at least you're not like that bye
yes it's just everyday okay so all the
participants now going back into the
session room so like other academic
conferences they have sessions for like
two hours and a coffee break and then
session then lunch yeah that kind of
structure so this was just a brief
little break for them and a chance to
meet to talk to them so what you saw
upstairs was basically a kind of boring
conference we could have been anywhere
this however is the venue of the
conference it is a literal palace so if
you look behind me the wall absolutely
gorgeous the ceilings of tiled and just
through here there's an amazing
courtyard like it's gorgeous and sunny
and I mean look at these who do these
things I don't even know what they are
but they're pretty also bats was
described to me that other was described
as a small chapel as I was discussing
with them sand bank stuff yesterday the
venue the opulence of it the security
kind of feel like I'm in a Bond film
right now this is of all the like travel
opportunities that YouTube's given me
this is definitely up there
[Music]
in models where you have to make
assumptions and maybe you don't agree on
the assumptions and I don't know is that
not the case in other sciences that
researchers have different opinions yes
it's not enough for announcer no now I
am editing so we recorded all these
interviews yesterday you might have even
been seeing some footage from
interspersed throughout this video and I
had any to put that together into an
intelligent video about economics which
is so far going surprisingly smoothly
what I've done so far is code the
interviews which is to say I written
down the timestamps of when things
happen in the interviews and then based
on a script which I wrote yesterday I'm
basically slotting them in to the
timeline and then I'll going to be
filming a bunch of stuff later to put
between those edits so most of today is
going to be this video I think so I'm
not gonna have much of a chance to talk
to people other than the break this
morning so heads down today hopefully
tomorrow we're gonna add a bit more of a
a chance to talk to people as office
views go that's not bad so it is much
later it is dark outside and earlier we
went out to shoot the last bits for this
feature video which I'm editing at the
moment was shooting the best of camera a
cat turned up at one point which is very
exciting a cat donut okay and also we
had security called on us that was fun
right now we just got the last set of
comments from the bank
we sent a draft to them very rough draft
that I've been editing today and I've
already followed in the new footage and
now what we're doing is taking action on
their suggestions and getting this thing
ready it's about ten o'clock now so
hopefully we won't be here for too much
longer than a couple more hours and
we'll get something which can come out
to the world on my channel tomorrow
which is exciting actually I think this
is gonna be a good video
[Music]
so rationality in economics is something
very different personality as you know
and not a column so think about it for a
person outside of academic economics
rationality means acting in a vision
reasonable way now when someone decide
to steal something from a shop maybe
it's right in front of a police station
maybe that's not a rational action
because it's unreasonable for an
economist rationality means behaving in
the way in which the model will predict
you behave say if there is a model that
explains why is that you may end up
stealing something yeah in fact behaving
very rationally so economists behave you
know ages behave rationally in models
because we've defined our final T in
this way so back here at the poster
session is currently 31 of the board
members of the Central Bank based class
to need all the phd's behind me and
there's gonna be this big kind of my
lots of photos and everything like that
so I'm here just try and snatch a few
things I did notice that they have these
very nice poster boards which people
been displaying their work on high tech
until you get to the bottom so just a
breeze block what has been interesting
and different to my academic experience
at conferences is the people here I
don't think there are around anymore
and the amount of media scrutiny of
these guys are under I mean they're up
to like a putter price for their posters
but they've have media scrutiny and
cameras over filming them some people
filming the people filming them like
this is layers of media interest that
you'd never see you know
I don't envy the amount of egg they're
having to go on camera and talk about
their work and talk to these really
important people
yeah I'd be intimidated as hell in case
I haven't mentioned it yes this venue is
absolutely gorgeous and I've kind of got
used to it this is now the new normal
just yeah you know fine background
[Music]
sure my name is Jim stock I'm a
professor in the Harvard Economics
Department and I work on a variety of
different topics including econometrics
macroeconomics and environmental
economics and climate change so that's
one opportunity didn't get very often so
I recorded a bunch of stuff with
Professor stock to using future videos
basically stuff I might imagine I'm
going to talk about which I was always
just interested in
sure well that's a terrific question
well the stranded asset problem is one
if there's investments that have been
made that then become less valuable or
adds not possible to being used as a
result of changing regulations so for
example in the United States if there's
investments that are made in new mining
potential and then we make then we make
changes in regulations that make it
impossible to get at those assets or use
the value of those assets and those
become stranded and they lose their
value I think a analysis of previous
divestment campaigns
suggests that the marginal value of
divestment defined narrowly is fairly
small that is if one entity chooses not
to hold a particular asset not to buy
coal companies or have them in their
portfolio that's an opportunity for an
investment by a hedge fund somewhere
else because they might be able to buy
them a little cheaper and then make more
of a profit so overall in terms of the
ability of coal companies for example
since we're talking about that to get to
get to get investment in them it's it's
it's I'm not I don't see that as having
a big first round effect
one advantage of divestment campaigns is
that weight raises awareness of some of
these issues so I think a broader
awareness of the problems of climate
change a broader awareness of the need
for us to move from fossil fuel to
renewable resources to low co2
alternatives that's very important it's
possible that divestment complains
contribute to that general awareness
what's also happened is the video has
been published so the only economic
video has gone out and it seems to have
been very well received
like people seem to like it lots of
great feedback people send their you
know that it's an interesting topic
which you know obviously my audience
isn't an economics based audience so
that is a win as far as I'm concerned
so we've almost like to come
Media Hub recently people and gorgeous
is this it's the kitchen for the palace
absolutely beautiful and you know this
is just the office for the day in this
gorgeous room Oh step through the storm
would you look at that I mean that's
absolutely beautiful corridor and look
here this is absolutely a mix it's been
looking courtyard like it's oh okay and
what's through here let's have a look oh
just a casual reading room small
fireplace over here
nice understated ceiling a little bit of
at the end I picked the wrong PhD you
guys so an hour entering the final
stages of the conference there's the
last personal session that's happening
at the moment with really important
people like that the head of the Bank of
Japan is on stage at the moment along
with the head of the European Central
Bank and just after that they're going
to announce the winner of this
competition all the PhDs have been
entered in with their posters and I am
the person going up that stage to
interview one of them live on the
internet no pressure there in their
Twitter account and he has like 400,000
people following it'd be fine
[Music]
okay so we just did a live interview I'm
here with Michelle who was the joint
winner of the young columnist poster
prize we just had a life interview where
I may be slightly missed the fact that
there was a queue given it was yeah
what's my queue to begin so you're gonna
go like wave the flag or something and
if the light is on that camera is active
presumably hello I'm Simon Clark and I'm
here in Sintra Portugal with the
European Central Bank and you I mean
you've explained it in other people's
blogs so in other videos that what
you've done I mean how what about you
feeling very good feeling a little bit
embarrassed or a little bit stressed but
we were both just saying after the
interview it's nice now we've been here
too tight I am pent up in hotel the
conference now we can actually see a bit
of Portugal because it looks amazing out
there so that's the plan for tomorrow
but um yeah I'm glad you won let me
represent some Oxford's prior to me
currently walking home but I've got my
torch on because I was warned about
snakes apparently there are snakes on
the street at home probably not
poisonous because it's any Portugal but
all the same probably a good precaution
okay so it's Thursday now let me tell
you how this date of the vlog was
supposed to go I was going to be coming
to sintra the actual village of sintra
in Portugal and see how beautiful it was
I'm in sintra and the weather is
absolutely awful ah it's raining again
this is pegging awful what's the deal
Portugal I wanted to try making a video
about our lovely your countries and how
it's been really sunny the past couple
of days when I've been stuck inside it
was sunny but no if I wanted drizzle on
a lingering sense of disappointment I
would have stayed in the UK obviously I
want to make the most of the situation
like yes it's raining but I'm in a
gorgeous place tom is a
giving myself about 19 minutes so for
those who know simcha there's a
beautiful palace which is like up on the
hill there's enough time to get there
look at it and get back for my flight
so I've just kind of bone myself here
and mouth just stuck somewhere which is
beautiful which I can't see because of
the rain I can't see the most the best
thing about it which will be indoors so
I've taken shelter in this very rickety
old train station and I'm just gonna
wait out the rain and see see how that
goes okay so the rain is a better just
long enough to give me literally just a
few minutes I'm going to be in the old
town just up here for about five minutes
it's still a bit grim and a bit British
but at least I'm gonna get to see
something and you can show you something
they have a Worley wagon
[Music]
[Music]
okay so my five minutes here
I tell me to cover if I'd wanted to see
what's inside its building I wanna go to
the castle look I haven't even showed
you the castle look at this
yeah more time and more Sun needed let's
go home time to go to the airport
so just the right back at Stansted and I
mean that kind of delirious state my
phone's dead and I just want to go home
and tired
there is something and I don't know what
it is I think it's a door shutting
somewhere in the station which is
exactly the first three notes of his
star by Smash Mouth it's one more bright
in the mood
[Music]
[Music]
I'm headed back home and I just wanted
to round off this video by saying thank
you so much to the ECB for inviting me
to Portugal I had a fantastic time I
apologize that I couldn't get more
answers to your questions but that was
just the way that this conference works
I you know I hope that the answers you
got were interesting but I hope you
enjoyed it and I hope it kind of
communicated that it was this incredible
experience that I had in Portugal the
the palace was beautiful the people I
was working with were great I think
we've got a really interesting video out
and hopefully you and I learned
something a little bit about economics
along the way thank you for watching
thank you again to the ECB for inviting
me I loved working with you guys and if
you guys actually want to learn more
about the research that was being
discussed I'll leave a link just below
the like button to the abstracts
actually to the full papers of the the
PhD students submitted for this poster
competition so if you're interested in
economics check out the full papers
because the titles look really
interesting thank you for watching I
hope you enjoyed and I'll see you in the
next video
[Music]
[Music]